Dune part two is coming on March 1st are
you ready for it after seeing the
trailer is one of the most exciting
aspects of this film is what it looks
like and we have a feeling that this
movie will exceed our expectations when
it comes to cinematography from IMAX
cameras infrared scenes and of course
those sandworms we've got the details on
what will make this movie look so epic
let's get into it you couldn't get
amazing cinematography without an
amazing cinematographer when it comes to
cinematography Dune part two has plenty
to live up to after all Greg Fraser won
the 2022 Academy Award for best
cinematography Fraser is back once again
so we can expect a similar visual vibe
to what the first movie gave us yet we
have reason to believe that this one
will be even more visually impressive
back in 2021 when they had just started
the ball rolling for the franchise's
second installment Fraser told
Entertainment Weekly quote I've read the
script and I'm more Blown Away than I
was by part one now that's some serious
Kudos we've seen the trailers and just
how amazing these shots look and Fraser
was proud in particular about the World
building that technology allows I mean
what is super exciting now you can
convince everybody that that's possible
it's no surprise that returning to the
Dune set after rapping one movie and
starting on the next must feel like
you're entering a new world it was a
dream to return to the world of Dune
it's great being bag it feels like I
never left clearly leading man Timothy
shalam is just as Amazed by the world of
Dune as fans are and what Dune part two
has in store exceeded his expectations
but honestly I love everything I've been
in but this might be the project I'm
most proud of director Den venu called
Dune part two a cinematic blast and
according to Shalom what he meant by
that is there's a there a certain level
of World building in the first one that
is ultra detailed but is laying the
ground networ clearly there will be a
lot more in Dune part two than there was
in part one the movie will cover the
second half of the novel and has a
nearly 3-hour runtime there will be time
jumps intense action scenes and a lot
more to learn about the inworld politics
and that means fans will see more of the
world of Dune than we did in the first
film if you know anything about Dune or
have seen the trailers then you know one
very important element of this second
installment is the sand Wars while we
heard about them in the first film and
caught a quick Glimpse we didn't get to
see them and yes since sandworms are a
mythical creature creating them was
Quite a feat in fact the team hadn't
even decided exactly how they would look
when filming the first film well there
was a whole worm unit on the movie
there's a two-minute sequence in the
movie or something like that that took
them four months to shoot or something
of course this was mostly CGI but there
were practical elements to make them
actually ridable there have been a few
trailers for Dune part part two released
and it's easy to see the breathtaking
visuals in all of them but you may have
also noticed some unexpected black and
white scenes most people probably
thought this was an unusual directorial
choice in reality though these shots
most likely won't actually look black
and white instead they're scenes that
were filmed in infrared this means that
these scenes capture a spectrum of
colors that humans can't actually see
images shot this way have a lot of
contrast and make the characters stand
out from the background this gives a
really unusual effect and while it's
unclear at this time how and exactly why
they chose to shoot some scenes this way
it's certainly going to add to the drama
this movie was made to be seen in the
theaters in fact it was made to be seen
in IMAX during the early stages of
filming director Den venu spoke to
collider about using more IMAX cameras
he said definitely Greg Fraser and I we
fell in love with this format and
definitely there will be even probably
more IMAX footage in this movie
definitely and as it turns out Dune Part
Two Shot entirely in IMAX unlike the
first movie 40% of which was filmed that
way there's only one way to watch this
movie and it's like the with speakers
and yes you should see it in IMAX 70 mm
if you have the opportunity since this
will give the audience the most
immersive option for watching the film
do you think the cinematography in Dune
part two will be better than the first
film do you plan on seeing it in Max
let's discuss in the comments and for
more updates on all the best upcoming
movies make sure to like And subscribe
to the things